[موسيقى]
انا بيكون في حصادي الليله معكم عبد
القادر عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
وحدات وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من
العالم البدايه من نيويورك وتحديدا من
مبنى الامم المتحده حيث عقدت جلسه مفتوحه
لمجلس الامن طالب خلالها المنسق الاموي
الخاص لعمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط
اسرائيل بوقف هدم الممتلكات الفلسطينيه
ثم الى هذه الصور من اتلانتا من امام
محكمه مقاطعه فولتن بولايه جورجيا
الامريكيه والمرتقب ان يمثل امامها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الخميس او
الجمعه للرد على التهم المواجهه اليه
بمحاوله التلاعب بنتائج الانتخابات في
الولايه
ثم الى لندن حيث اصدر القضاء البريطاني
عقوبه السجن المؤبد بدون امكانيه الحصول
على افراج المشروط بحق ممرضه انجليزيه
اودينت بقتل سبعه اطفال حديثي الولاده
وباتت بفعلتها
اسوا قاتله اطفال في تاريخ المملكه
المتحده الحديثه
ثم الى هذه الصور المباشره من جزيره هاواي
التي تشهد دمارا واسعا ناجما عن حرائق
الغابات الاخيره في منطقه ماوي وسيزور
الرئيس بايدن المنطقه لمعاينه ولقاء
الناجين والرد على الانتقادات التي وجهت
لحكومته بسبب استجاباتها البطيئه للكارثه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
مقتل مستوطنه واصابه اخر بجروح خطيره في
اطلاق نار في الخليل وانسحاب المنفذين
الاحتلال يدفع بتعزيزات ونتنياهو يتحدث عن
ذروه هجمات بدعم من ايران واتباعها وحماس
والجهاد تعتبران العمليه ردا طبيعيا
ومشروعا على الاستيطان والانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه
معركه سلاح المدرعات تتصدر المشهد
الميداني في السودان الدعم السريع ينشر
صورا لما وصفه بسيطره قواته على المقر
جنوبي الخرطوم والمتحدث باسم الجيش يؤكد
للجزيره صد الهجمات على سلاح المدرعات
والخارجيه السودانيه تدعو المجتمع الدولي
لتقديم الدعم اللازم للحكومه
روسيا واوكرانيا تتبادلان هجمات بالمسيرات
الهجمات تجبر روسيا على تعليق العمل في
عدد من مطارات العاصمه وضمن جولته
الاوروبيه زيلينسكي يتحدث عن مزيد من
الدعم الاوروبي لاستخدام مقاتلات اف 16 في
المعارك
موسكو تقول ان الخطوه ستصاعد الحرب
ترى انها سترجح كفتها
في تعاقد جديد امام جهود انهاء الازمه في
النيجر مجموعه دول غرب افريقيا ايكواس
ترفض اعلان قاده الانقلاب فتره انتقاليه
من ثلاث سنوات والمانيا تحذر من تهديد
يتزايد لامن منطقه الساحل وتقول ان
الانقلاب عرقل خطط سحب قواتها من المنطقه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم المسارات
المحتمله للمشهد في سوريا في ظل احتجاجات
بالسويداء وكذلك درعا تمديدا بترد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والامنيه
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في ضوء استمرار
الاحتجاجات في السويداء ودرعا ما هي
توقعاتكم وما هي توقعاته طبعا وقد جاءت
اجاباتكم على النحو التالي
34% قالوا انه سيكون هناك خطوات تصعيد
اكبر ضد النظام من المحتجين بينما توقع
نحو 18% ان تصدر قرارات الاقتصاديه رسميه
تؤدي للحصار الاحتجاجات واخيرا توقع 48%
اي واجهه النظام لاحتجاجات بالقمع الامني
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم الدخول على صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
الاحتجاجات في السويداء ودرعا تتواصل
لليوم الثالث على التوالي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوه الاحتلال مدينه الخليل منطقه
عسكريه مغلقه وسدت جميع مداخلها بالحواجز
العسكريه جاء ذلك عقب مقتل مستوطنه واصابه
مستوطن اخر بجروح خطيره في عمليه اطلاق
نار قرب مجمع مستوطنات كريات اربعه بمدينه
الخليل جنوبي الضفه الغربيه المحتله كما
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوه الاحتلال
اقتحمت عددا من المناطق والبلدات بحثا عن
منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار هذا واعتبرت حركه
حماس ان العمليه جاءت ردا على الاستيطان
فيما حذرت الجهاد بان القادمه اشد واقصى
فشل جديد لحاله الاستنفار الامنيه
الاسرائيليه يترجمه مقتل مستوطنه واصابه
اخر في هجوم فلسطيني مسلح جنوبي الخليل
جيش الاحتلال الذي اغلق مداخل المدينه اكد
في تحقيقاته الاوليه ان مسلحين اثنين
شاركا في الهجوم من خلال اطلاق عشرات
الرصاصات صدمه تقل عددا من المستوطنين قرب
ما يعرف بمنطقه الفحص على الطريق الرابط
بين مستوطنتي بيت حجاي وكريات اربع كما
عثرت قواته على سياره محترقه في شمالي
المدينه يعتقد انه استخدمت في الهجوم
المسلح
هجوم الخليل ياتي في وقت تواصل فيه قوات
الاحتلال حملتها الامنيه في قرى وبلدات
جنوبيه نابلس لليوم الثالث على التوالي
بهدف الوصول الى منفذ هجوم حواره الذي
اصفر عن مقتل اسرائيليين
وتركزت عمليات البحث في بلده عقربه حيث
اغلقت محاورها وعطرت حياه المواطنين فيها
على جميع المستويات الطريقه التي يعمل بها
الاسرائيليون الحقت الضرر كبير بالمسيره
التعليميه الحقت ضرر في الحركه التجاريه
والصناعيه بلده عقربه هي بلده مركزيه
وكبيره وفيها عدد كبير من المصانع
وبالتالي هذا الاغلاق هو يؤثر على الحركه
التجاريه والصناعيه في بلده عقربه
اجراءات الاحتلال العقابيه ترافقت ايضا مع
اعتداءات المستوطنين بالزجاجات الحارقه
على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين في قريه
بورينجنوبيه نابلس ما اسفر عن وقوع اضرار
ماديه اهدافهم
هذا حامي جبل كامل
بين هجمات فلسطينيه مسلحه ضد الاسرائيليين
واستمرار السلطات الاحتلال سياسيا وامنيا
في معاقبه الفلسطينيين الى جانب اعتداءات
المستوطنين يبقى المشهد مرشحا لمزيد من
التوتر والتصعيد سمير ابو شماله الجزيره
نابلس فلسطين
هذا وتهم رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو في تصريحات ادلى بها من
موقع عمليه اطلاق النار في الخليل اتخذ
ايران ومن وصفهم باتباعها بالوقوف وراء
ذروه الهجوم الارهابي بالخليل حسب تعبيره
واضاف نتنياهو ان الحكومه والجيش يعملان
للوصول الى من وصفهم بالقتله ومن ارسلوهم
لمحاسبتهم على ذلك وفق ما قال
نحن في ذروه هجوم ارهابي هذا الهجوم يتم
بتشجيع وتمويل وتوجيه من ايران واتباعها
نعمل على مدار الساعه من اجل القبض على
القتله وكل من يحاول قتل مواطني اسرائيل
وقد وصلنا حتى اليوم اليهم جميعا وسنصل
الى هؤلاء الذين نفذوا جريمه اليوم يجب ان
يفهم الجميع ان جزءا كبيرا من موجه
الارهاب الراهنه تتم بتوجيهات خارجيه ونحن
نستخدم وسائل هجوميه ودفاعيه كي نصفي
الحساب مع القتله ومع مرسليهم القريبين
والبعدين
قال المنسق الامامي الخاص لعمليه السلام
في الشرق الاوسط
ان عدم احراز تقدم سياسي يعالج القضايا
الجوهريه للقضيه الفلسطينيه ترك فراغا
خطيرا ملاه من وصفهم بالمتطرفين داعيا
خلال جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن الدولي الى
محاسبه جميع المسؤولين عن اعمال العنف
والارهاب ووقف هدم ممتلكات الفلسطينيين
مع التصاعد العنف اجدد التاكيد على انه
يجب محاسبه جميع الجنات وتقديمهم بسرعه
الى العداله في السابع عشر من اغسطس تم
هدم مدرسه ابتدائيه فلسطينيه في عين ساميه
قبل ايام من بدء العام الدراسي وهو ثالث
هدم من نوعه في العام الماضي ادعو السلطات
الاسرائيليه الى انهاء عمليات هدم ممتلكات
الفلسطينيين والموافقه على خطط اضافيه
تمكن الفلسطينيين من البناء بشكل قانوني
وتلبيه احتياجاتهم التنمويه
ينضم الينا من الناصره وديع وعوده الباحث
المختص في الشعر
وديع باعتقادك ما تفسير
توجيه الحكومه توجيه نتنياهو الاتهام الى
ايران بانها هي من تقف خلف من ينفذون هذه
العمليات ما تفسير ذلك وما الهدف منه
برايك
نعم الاستخبارات العسكريه المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه الحاكمه بشكل عام في الشهور
الاخيره توجه اصبع الاتهام الى ايران
وبالتحديد الى الجهاد الاسلامي الذي يتلقى
هذه المساعدات ربما يكون يعني بين هذا
وشيك شيء من الحقيقه لكن نتنياهو بالتركيز
على الملف الايراني طالما
كانت هناك اسباب غير معلنه يلوح نتنياهو
منذ سنوات
بالفزعه الايرانيه في محاوله لصرف انظار
الاسرائيليين والعالم بان المشكله ليست
الاحتلال انما هناك دوله تحرض على على
اسرائيل وتؤدي الى توتير الاضواء الاوضاع
في المنطقه وهذه محاوله خبيثه يعني تغطيه
الحقيقه وكان لولا ايران لما كانت هناك
مقاومه فلسطينيه وهذه مغالطه كبيره هذا
كذب بطبيعه الحال وهناك محاوله ليطمئن
الاسرائيليين وكان يعني هناك عامل جديد
دخل على الخط وبالتالي هذا هذه محاوله
لتخفيف وطئه الفشل خاصه
قد وعد الاسرائيليين في العام الماضي
حينما كان رئيسا المعارضه بانه لو كان في
سده الحكومه لقضى بقضاء مبرما على الارهاب
الفلسطيني بين مزدوجين ليجد نفسه الان وقد
تحول الى رسم كاريكاتير في ظل هذه
العمليات الفلسطينيه حتى الان هناك اكثر
من 35 قتيل اسرائيلي منذ بدء العام وهذا
عدد يعني يزيد عن عدد القتل الاسرائيليين
في كل العام الماضي وهل هذا ما يقال في
داخل اسرائيل من مختلف الوسائل اي توجيه
اللوم لايران ام هناك ابعاد اخرى
هذه الروايه هي بالاساس روايه اسرائيليه
رسميه ولكن هناك اوساط امنيه يعني
اسرائيليه واسعه تؤكد ذلك ولكن بخلاف
الموقف الرسمي وبخلاف موقف نتنياهو عدد
كبير من المراقبين والجنرالات في الاحتياط
يضيفون يقولون ان هناك دورا ايرانيا
متصاعدا في المنطقه وهو نوع من الثائر
للعمل الاسرائيليه في سوريا وغير سوريا
ولكن بالتاكيد هم يؤكدون ان هناك احتلال
وان هناك افق سياسي مفقود في الضفه
الغربيه هناك انهيار للسلطه الفلسطينيه في
اشاره الى مدى نجاعه واهميه دور التنسيق
الامني في السابق وهناك طبعا يعني
استعراض اسرائيلي لعوامل اخرى يتجاهلها
بقوله نحن في ذروه هجوم
ما الذي قراته بهذا الكلام هذا تصريح
هو يحاول ان يقول ان اسرائيل تتعرض الى
هجمه كبيره غير اعتياديه استثنائيه في
محاوله مبطنه لتبرير فشل حكومته في
مواجهات هذه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المتصاعده في الضفه الغربيه خاصه وان هناك
اتهامات في اسرائيل كثيره وتزداد حتى في
هذه الساعات بشكل غير مالوف في اسرائيل
تشير الى دور
الاستفزاز الذي يمارسه عدد من الوزراء
وعدد من القاده المستوطنين مشاريع
الاستيطان التهويد الحديث السافر على
موضوع ضم الضفه الغربيه الاعلان عن مشروع
كبير لبناء 155 بؤره استطانيه وتحويل
ملايين الشواكل ملايين الدولارات الى هذا
الموضوع كل ذلك يدفع اوساط اسرائيليه ايضا
الى توجيه الانتقادات الى حكومه نتانياه
وبانها تشمل عددا من الوزراء الغيبيين ممن
لا توجد لهم اي تجربه في الامن وبالتالي
هم يورطون اسرائيل في هذا المازق الكبير
مع الشعب الفلسطيني خاصه وان كما كنا لا
توجد هناك اي افاق سياسيه تريح او تريح
الجانب الفلسطيني او تبعث على الامل بان
هناك تسويه على الطريق من الناصره وديع
الباحثه المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني العميد
نبيل عبد الله للجزيره انما وصفها
بميليشيا الدعم السريع المتمرده جددت
الهجوم على مقر سلاح المدرعات بالخرطوم
وان الجيش السوداني تصدى لها واجبرها على
الفرار من ارض المعركه وكانت قوه الدعم
السريه قد قالت انها تمكنت من الدخول الى
مقر سلاح المدرعات التابع للجيش السوداني
في منطقه جبرا جنوبي الخرطوم
مقر سلاح المدرعات ومحيطه ساحه سجال
واشتباك ساخنه في اليوم السادس والعشرين
بعد المئه من القتال بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع تلك القوات قالت ونشرت
صورا تؤكد انها دخلت الى مقر سلاح
المدرعات بمنطقه جبرا الله اكبر
تسلل محدود فقط هكذا رد مصدر بالجيش
السوداني في تصريح للجزيره مشيرا الى ان
طائرات الجيش قصفت اهدافا للدعم السريع
قرب مقر المدرعات وان مجموعه فقط تسللت
داخل المقر من الناحيه الشرقيه وسط معارك
محتدمه بين الجانبين محيط سلاح المدرعات
يشهد منذ ثلاثه ايام معارك ضاريه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع التي تسعى
للسيطره عليه باعتباره اقوى اسلحه الجيش
السوداني على مساحه 20 كيلومترا مربعا يقع
سلاح المدرعات على مسافه نحو 12 كيلومترا
الى جنوب مقر القياده العامه يضم المقر 5
كتائب دبابات يقدر عددها بنحو 75 دبابه
ومهبطا بديلا للطائرات تكمن اهميته
الاستراتيجيه في القتال الدائري حاليا
باعتباره النقطه الاخيره الحاسمه الفاصله
بين تمركزات وامدادات قوات الدعم السريع
الحاليه والقياده العامه
بعد سقوط معسكر اليرموك وقياده الاحتياطي
المركزي في جنوب الخرطوم في يد قوات الدعم
السريع معارك محيط سلاح المدرعات خلفت
قتلى وجرحى في طرفي القتال وسط انباء عن
سقوط مدنيين ايضا بسبب تضرر مناطق سكنيه
قريبه بالقصف الجوي والارضي المعارك ايضا
دائره في اوميدرمان غردي العاصمه
السودانيه اشتباكات بمختلف انواع الاسلحه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وتحليق وقصف
لطائرات الجيش ومسيراته قابله تصدي
بمضادات ارضيه للدعم السريع في ولايه جنوب
دارفور تبقى العاصمه نيالا بؤره ساخنه
للقتال وان هدات قليلا نعت قياده القوات
المسلحه اللواء ياسر فضل الله الخضر قائد
الفرقه 16 مشاه قائله انه اغتيل الاثنين
في نياله بينما تتحدث مصادر محليه للجزيره
عن وصول قوات كبيره من الحركات الموقعه
على اتفاق جبال السلام بهدف حمايه
المدنيين وممتلكاتهم
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه دعت المجتمع
الدولي الى تقديم الدعم اللازم للحكومه
السودانيه لتطلع بدورها في التصدي لما
وصفته بميليشيا الدعم السريع المتمرده
وحمايه الامن الوطني واتهمت الخارجيه
السودانيه في بيان لها قوات الدعم السريع
بارتكاب ممارسات وحشيه تمثل اساليب
الجماعات الارهابيه مثل ترويع المجتمعات
وارتكاب اعمال القتل والنهب والعدوان لفرض
اجندتها السياسيه مشيره الى تقارير
وانباترت عن اختطاف ميليشيا الدعم السريع
لاعداد كبيره من النساء واستخدامهن اعماله
قصريه وتعريضه للاغتصاب ومطالبه ذويهن
بالفيديو كما اتهمت الخارجيه السودانيه في
بيانها قوات الدعم السريع بتجنيد اطفال
القصر وان ذلك جرى كشفه خلال هجوم قوات
الدعم السريع على سلاح المدرعات
وقال مفوض الشؤون الانسانيه بولايه شرق
دارفور محمد احمد عيسى قال للجزيره ان نحو
150,000 نازح وصلوا من مدينه الضعين
بعاصمه الولايه نتيجه القتال الدائر بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع منذ
ابريل المنصرم وقالت غرفه الطوارئ مدينه
نيالا ان الحرب خلفت اوضاعا كارثيه في
المدينه تمثلت اثارها في انعدام الموارد
الاساسيه للحياه
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو هو سيد مزمل
ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بك سيد مزمل لنبدا بهذه الصوره الغامضه
والغير محسومه حتى الان فيما يتعلق بمنشاه
المدرعات وهذه البيانات المتضاربه من
نسيطر ومن استطاع الدفع بقوات الطرف الاخر
ماذا عن هذا المشهد التحيه لك استاذ
عبدالله المشاهدين قوات الدعوه السريع سعت
الى استهداف قوات سلاح المدرعات منذ فتره
بعزلها
باحتلال الكتيبه الاستراتيجيه شمالا ومصنع
اليرموك وقوات الاحتياط المركزي المعسكر
الخاص لقوات الاحتياطي المركزي جنوبا
لعزلها عن اي سنه لانها تعرف قيمه سلاح
المدرعات بالنسبه للجيش السوداني وفي
المقابل اتبعت قياده الجيش السوداني
اسلوبا غريبا في الدفاع عن هذه المغرات
باتباع نهج الدفاع من على الاسوار ثبت فشل
هذا
الخيار في الاستراتيجيه وفي اليرموك وفي
الاحتياط المركزي وهو يتكرر مع المدرعات
القوات الدعم السريع رمت بكل ثقلها امس
واليوم سعيا منها
لاحتلال المدرعات والسيطره عليها فشلت
بالامس وتم صدها
بعيدا قليلا عن الاسوار اليوم نجحت في هدم
السور الشرقي لسلاح المدرعات
باليه ثقيله وظلت هذه الاليه تهدم في صوره
الشرقي لاكثر من نصف ساعه نصف ساعه من دون
ان تتعرض لا يطلق نار
وافلحت فعلا
والدعم السريع في ان تقتحم الجانب الشرقي
من سلاح المدرعات بقوه كبيره ولكن القوه
الموجوده داخل سلاح المدرعات استبسلت
ونجحت في طرط قوات الدعم السريع من داخل
سلاح المدرعات ولكن كل تاكيد يتوقع
المراقبون ان هذه المحاولات ستزداد
وستتواصل واذا لم تغير قياده الجيش
التكتيك الذي تستخدمه في الدفاع عن مقراته
عموما سلاح المدرعات على وجه الخصوص فقط
تسقط المدرعات في يد
متمرديه
على الاقل السيناريو او سيناريوهان في حال
حدوثهما ماذا لو تمكنت قوات الدعم السريع
من السيطره على هذه المنشات ما الذي سيحدث
على صعيد مراكز القوى او الثقل كما ذكرت
هي لم تفلح حتى هذه اللحظه تم ترضع ولكن
اذا سقطت المدرعات وهي اقوى سلاح للجيش
السوداني في المجمل وفي الخرطوم على وجه
التحديد اذا سقطت المدرعات في يد قوه
الدعم السريع فسيكون الطريق امامها مفتوحا
لمبنى القياده العامه للجيش وسيمنحها
افضليه كبيره سيزعب على الجيش تعويض طيب
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان انظمه دفاعاتها
الجويه احبطت اليوم محاوله اوكرانيه
لاستهداف مواقع في ضواحي موسكو بطائرتين
مسيرتين وقد نشرت وسائل اعلام روسيه مشاهد
قالت انها لاسقاط انظمه الدفاع الروسيه
مسيرتين قربى العاصمه
كما اعلنا حاكم مقاطعه موسكو عن اصابه
شخصين جراء سقوط حطام طائره مسيره في
منطقه استرا من جانبها افادت الوكاله
الروسيه للنقل الجوي بتغيير مسارات نحو 50
طائره بسبب القيود المفروضه على مطارات
موسكو وقالت وسائل اعلام روسيه انه جرس
استئناف العمليات بصوره طبيعيه بمطار
فونكوفو بعد تحطم طائره مسيره اوكرانيه
فوق منطقه موسكو كما استانف السلطات مطار
العمل بالمطار بعد تقييد السلطات للرحلات
الجويه
وفي ساحه المعارك في اوكرانيا قالت نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هانا مليار ان قوه
بلادها تتقدم جنوب مدينه
واستعاده السيطره على ثلاثه كيلومترات
مربعه في محيط المدينه الواقعه في مقاطعه
دونيسك وعلى صعيد جبهه خار كيف وصفت مليار
الوضع في محيط مدينه كوبيانس بالصعب
تجري المعارك في الجهتين الشماليه
والجنوبيه في الشمال يحاول العدو اخراج
قواتنا من المواقع التي سيطرت عليها في
المرتفعات خاصه انه بات محاصرا هناك اما
جنوب المدينه فقواتنا تتقدم اما في اتجاه
كوبيانسك فالوضع صعب والقتال مستمر وجميع
الهجمات الروسيه باءت بالفشل
وينضم الينا من جناب العقيد الكسندر رئيس
تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسيه سيد حتى
الان الجانب الروسي يؤكد بانه اسقط عددا
كبيرا من هذه المعركه معركه المسيرات التي
وصلت حتى الى العاصمه موسكو فهل معنى ذلك
عدم فاعليه هذه العمليات
هي ليست عزيمه الفاعليه وفي الحقيقه لو ان
واحده او بضعه من هذه
المسيره تستطيع
اختراق المجال الجوي وتضرب اهداف من البنى
التحتيه الاساسيه مثل المطارات واهداف
مدنيه عسكريه يمكن ان تشيع الكثير من
الفوضى والكلفه الاقتصاديه الباهظه حتى
الان الجانب الروسي يقلل من فاعليه ما
تقوم به هذه المسير يدخله في اطار الدعايه
الاعلاميه فقط
طبيعي هم يقللون من اهميه هذا الهجمات لكن
للاسف اذا ما لقينا نظره على الارقام
وان نقول بقدر كبير من اليقين ان نقول ان
اربعه في المئه من
المجموع القاذفات الاستراتيجيه
لسلاح الجو الروسي قد تم تدميرها عن طريق
هذه المسيرات اذا هذا امر لا ينبغي
الاستهانه به ارجو ان تبقى معي سيد
بطرافير قد نقلت وكاله طاس الروسيه
للانباء عن وزاره الدفاع في موسكو ان وفدا
عسكريا ايرانيا وصل الى العاصمه الروسيه
لبحث التعاون بين القوات البريه في
البلدين واضافت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قائد القوات البريه الروسيه ونظيره
الايراني اتفقا على زياده التعاون بين
جيشي البلدين يذكر ان ايران تتهم غربيا
ببيع اعداد كبيره من المسيرات لروسيا
لاستخدامها في حربها على اوكرانيا وهو ما
تنفيه طهران
نحو افق جديد الى هناك يريد الروس
والايرانيون ان يحمل علاقات بينهم لا تنفك
تتوثق في الشق العسكري يبدو انه ماضون نحو
التنسيق التام بين جيشي البلدين
والبلدان الخاضعان معا لضغوط وعقوبات
اقتصاديه غربيه لهما في الاساس مواقف
متناغمه ازاء جمله من الملفات وساحات
الصراع لكن المسافه بين موسكو وطهران
تقلصت اكثر في غمره الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا التي تستزيد المدد الغربيه في
تلك الحرب قررت الدنمارك وهولندا اخيرا
تزويدها بمقاتلات اف 16 لدعم هجومها
المضاد على القوات الروسيه
واشنطن التي اعطت الضوء الاخضر للخطوه
تنبه في المقابل الى ان العلاقات بين
روسيا وايران تحسنت لتصبح شراكه دفاعيه
كامله
والحقيقه ان روسيا وايران لا توقدان
العلاقات على الصعيد العسكري وحسب
شهدت السنوات الاخيره تجاذب المصالح
بينهما في انشطه التجاره والطاقه والاسلحه
وحتى المشاريع النوويه ربما يكشف ذلك بعضا
من الابعاد الاستراتيجيه لسياسات روسيا في
منطقه يراد فيها الحد من النفوذ الامريكي
بنسبه لطهران الطامحه ايضا للانضمام الى
مجموعه بريكس الاقتصاديه قد يشكل هذا
النهج سبيلا للالتفاف على العقوبات
الغربيه المفروضه عليها منذ سنوات بسبب
برنامجها النووي كما انها تحتاج لانشاء
ممرات تجاريه مباشره تربطها مع اسيا
وروسيا
وليست اقل حاجه لصوت روسي داعم في المحافل
الدوريه
اما موسكو فلعلها من خلال تعزيز نفوذها في
تحالف بلاس والاستثمار في الطاقه
الايرانيه ستقترب من السيطره على سوق
الطاقه العالمي وممراته الاستراتيجيه
وسواء اكان المنحه اقتصاديا معسكريا فان
دراستنا امريكيه المتخصصه تنبه الى ان
التقارب الروسيه الايراني انما يتحدى
الضغوط الغربيه هذا محور جدل تقليدي بين
الاوساط الايرانيه ما زالت تتسائل عن جدوى
سياسه التوجه شرقا لخوض مواجهه مع الغرب
ضيفنا من جناب سيد
ربما تابعتها معنا في هذا التقرير وفد
عسكري ايراني في موسكو للبحث في التعاون
بين القوات البريه بين الدولتين كيف وجدت
هذا البعد
التعاون بين القوات المسلحه وكذلك
الحكومات حكومه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه وروسيا يزداد قوه وتعمقا على
مدى 15 عاما الماضيه
ومثير للاهتمام ان
المره الوحيده التي تعرضت ايران لغزو في
اكثر من 100 عام كان من قبل روسيا وهناك
تعاون في النزاع في سوريا وكنوع من تعزيز
الدفاعاتها ضد المتحده ايران تقترب اكثر
وطورت علاقات قريبه ومتينه مع روسيا لدرجه
انهما
حول سوريا ماذا عن زاويه التركيز ان
التعاون يتعلق بالقوات البريه بين
الدولتين فيما هناك اتهامات لايران بانها
تزود روسيا بالطائرات
الانتحاريه للجانب الروسي الموسيه طبعا
المسيره
هذه السيارات يتم تشغيلها من قبل طواقم
ارضيه وهي ليست بالضروره بايدي القوات
الجويه اعتقد ان ما وراء كل هذا علينا ان
نرى ان في ايران هناك ليس فقط مصالح
عسكريه بالمصالح سياسيه ومصالح اقتصاديه
الذين يديرون هذه الشركات يجنون الكثير من
الارباح من وراء بيع هذه المسيرات لروسيا
من جنيب العقيده الكسندر رئيس تحرير
المجله العسكريه السويسريه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تضيق فرص الدبلوماسيه بين قاده الانقلاب
في النيجر وبين المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا في اعقاب رفض المجموعه مقترحا
من قاده الانقلاب يتعهد بالعوده الى
النظام الديمقراطي بعد ثلاث سنوات وتاتي
هذه التطورات بعد زياره هي الثانيه لوفد
ايكواس الى العاصمه حيث التقى الوفد برئيس
المجلس العسكري الجنرال عبد الرحمن تيالي
وبالرئيس المقلوب محمد بازون لكن الوفد لم
يفصح عن نتائج مشاوراته في سياق تاكيد من
اكواس ان الخيار العسكري يظل قائما تقرير
فوزي بشرى
تتجه الازمه السياسيه في النيجر شيئا
فشيئا نحو اختبار للقوه لا يمنح لاي من
طرفي الصراع طرف الاختيار فالمجموعه
الاقتصاديه للدول غرب افريقيا اكواس تجد
نفسها في مازق لا يقل حرجا عما تواجهه
قياده الانقلاب في النيجر
تضع على الطاوله امرين اثنين اما حل
متفاوض عليه يعيد الحكم الدستوري ويمكن
الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازون من ممارسه
صلاحياته رئيسا والا فالتدخل العسكري
سيتكفل بهذه المهمه
وهذا باب في حراسه الديمقراطيه بالسلاح
متجاوز لمفهوم السياده الوطنيه ومصادر
للتعبيرات الدارجه عن حق الدول في التعاطي
مع ما تعتبره شانا داخليا
نريد للوضع الدستوري ان يعود باسرع وقت
ممكن بالنسبه الينا وفي نقاشاتنا هذه هي
الماده الوحيده على جدول الاعمال والا فان
تهديدنا باستخدام العمل العسكري ما زال
موجودا على الطاوله اما قاده ما يسمى
بالمجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن فهم ايضا
ليسوا اقل تصميما من اكواس في المضيء على
ما عزموا عليه مؤكدين ان لا عوده لبازوم
الى السلطه بل قالوا انهم ربما قدموه
لمحاكمه بتهم ترقى الى الخيانه
فالمجلس بقياده الجنرال عبد الرحمن تياني
شكل حكومته وهو يانس الى شارع مؤيد له
ومعارضه تقف معه لكنه ترك بابا مواربا اذا
رغبت اقواس ان تدخل من وهو العوده الى
النظام الديمقراطي بعد فتره انتقال تمتد
الى ثلاث سنوات ولا يتاخر مسؤول اكواس في
رفض المقترح نثريه
الفتره الانتقاليه غير مقبوله بالنسبه
لاكواس ولندخلها في مقايضات مع
الانقلابيين موقفنا واضح يجب ان يطلق سراح
الرئيس بازوم وان يفرج عن عائلته وزملائه
في الحكومه وان استعاد النظام الدستوري
وكانت اكواس رغم ما اعترى اجماعها من
نقصان برفض مالي وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا
لمقترح التدخل العسكري قد حسمت امر التدخل
بمقرره قاده اركان الجيوش احد عشر بلدا من
جمله خمسه عشر من انفاذ قرار التدخل الذي
حددوا اجله دون الافصاح عنه
مالي وبوركينا فاسو اخذتا قضيه الحرب ماخذ
الجد فارسلتا طائرات مقاتله الى النيجر
دعما لها وربما دفعا
تتحسبان له من تلقاء اكواس والدول الثلاث
بهذه الوضعيه في مواجهه اكواس تدخل جميعها
تجربه لا تعلم عواقبها الا بمقدار علم
الناس في النيجر وفي افريقيا عامه بمقدار
حظ الديمقراطيه وحظ المصالح في مشهد
النيجر الشديد للتعقيد
اكوارس المصممه على قطع الطريق على
الانقلابيين واعاده الرئيس المحتجز بازو
من السلطه تجد في فرنسا والمانيا ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بعامه ظهيرا مؤيدا
وداعما ومشجعا كل ذلك بدا جليل في لقاء
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
بنظيرتها السنغاليه ولا شاغل الا النيجر
وديمقراطيتها
الوضع معقد هناك فالانقلاب في النيجر اثر
على خطتنا للانسحاب من هذه المنطقه ندين
هذا الانقلاب الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعم ويرحب
بجهود اكواس لاحلال الديمقراطيه في
المنطقه ومن اجل دعم جهود اكواس علقنا
الاموال التي كنا نقدمها للنيجر ونعمل مع
المنظمه ضد الانقلابيين انها الديمقراطيه
ولا شيء اخر لكن ما لا يقال لا يخفى ثم تم
مشاعر كارهه لفرنسا في كل من النيجر ومالي
وبوركينا فاسو وثمت اقبال على دول اخرى
بحثا عن شروط نهوض بلا اكراهات وهل الدول
الاخرى غير روسيا والصين الدولتان اللتان
لا تنغصان على حاكم بحديث عن ديمقراطيه او
حقوق انسان هنا مقبن الازمه الافريقيه ليس
في النيجر وحدها وهنا ايضا معضله
الديمقراطيه التي يحمل عليها الناس حملا
بالتجريدات العسكريه
الديمقراطيه الحقه يصنعها اهلها ويحمونها
كذلك حين تدعو الحاجه اكواس ومن هم وراءها
يقولون بل بالسلاح تفرض
نفى الرئيس تشادي محمد ادريس ديبي مزاعم
بدخول قوه بريه من الجيش التشادي الى
الاراضي الليبيه لمطارده جماعه مسلحه
ارشاديه معارضه لكن ديبال انه لا مانع من
عبور القوات التشاديه الحدود الليبيه
استنادا الاتفاقيه الخرطوم بين اربع دول
مجاوره لليبيا تتيح مطارده المتمردين داخل
الاراضي الليبيه وقال مصدر في الرئاسه
الشاديه للجزيره ان الجيش قصف بالطائرات
مواقع مواقع الحركات المسلحه المعارضه
داخل الاراضي الليبيه وكانت جبهه الوفاق
من اجل التغيير المعارضه في تشاد قد اعلنت
مقتل اربعه من مسلحيها في القصف وقال عضو
الحركه محمد شريف جاكو ان قرابه 200 سياره
دفع رباعي من قوات الجيش التشادي تحركت
بغطاء جوي فرنسي لدخول الاراضي الليبيه
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان مظاهرات
مناهضه للنظام السوري خرجت في 36 نقطه
احتجاج بمحافظه السويداء جنوبي البلاد
واكدت المصادر ان المتظاهرين الذين خرجوا
احتجاجا على الاوضاع المعيشيه طالبوا
برحيل رموز النظام وخروج مؤسساته من
المحافظه وياتي ذلك تزامنا مع استمرار
الاضراب الذي دعا اليه ناشطون السوريون في
السويداء قبل ايام
[موسيقى]
مظاهرات محافظه السويداء تتواصل لليوم
الثالث على التوالي اكتست الاحتجاجات زخما
جديدا في مدينه السويداء في حين انضمت قرى
جديده الى الحراك السلمي وفق مواقع
اعلاميه محليه
كما ازدادت مطالب المتظاهرين وضوحا من
خلال الهتافات التي طالبت بخروج النظام
السوري
ومؤسساته من محافظه السويداء
ورددوا شعارات الثوره السوريه
وطالبوا من وصفوها بالمليشيات التي تدعمها
ايران بالخروج من مدينه السويداء ومن
القرى التي لها مقر فيها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاركه المرجعيه الدينيه الدرزيه في
المظاهرات اعطت دفعا كبيرا للمتظاهرين لما
يحمله ذلك من رمزيه عاليه عند سكان
المدينه وقد طالبت المرجعيه الدينيه حسب
ما تناقلته وسائل اعلام محليه
المتظاهرين بالحذر ممن وصفتهم بالمخربين
الذين يريدون حرف مسار الحراك السلمي
[موسيقى]
على عكس ساحه المدينه تبدو الشوارع
الرئيسيه فارغه وقد انحاز التجار الى
مطالب المتظاهرين بمواصله العصيان المدني
كما اغلق المتظاهرون الطرق المحافظه
الرئيسيه املا في دفع نظام السوري
للاستجابه لمطالبهم صهيب الخلف الجزيره
ادلب
ينضم الينا بالمدينه السويداء خالد جمول
الناشط السياسي ورئيس تجمع بنا الوطن سيد
خالد اهلا بك
ما الذي يجعل او جعل المطالب بعدما كانت
معيشيه واقتصاديه تتطور الى ان تصير مطالب
سياسيه
نعم مساء الخير مساء الخير لقناه الجزيره
وشكرا جزيلا على هذه التغطيه بطبيعه الحال
كما ترون ان محافظه السويداء وليس بجديد
عليها ان تخرج الى الشارع جماهيرها لتطالب
بحقوقها بشكل عام الجماهير اليوم خرجت
بشكل عفوي وليس كما ذكر على لسان احد
المعلقين بان هنالك ضواغط قد تكون معيشيه
الدورات المعاشيه قد تكون السبب من
الاسباب الرئيسيه ولكن السبب الاكبر هو ما
يتعرض له ما يتعرض له شعبنا ان كان في
السويداء والتي باقي المناطق من الضغوط
الاقتصاديه الضغوطه المعيشيه الضغوط
السياسيه هنالك هنالك نشر للفقر هنالك
انتشارا للفساد هنالك نشر للعنف تتعرض له
السويداء وباقي المناطق طبعا بطبيعه الحال
عندما ترون مجتمع او ترون شعب قد فقد
الامل تماما في المبادرات وفي القرارات
العموميه من الطبيعي ان يخرج الى الشارع
مطالبا في حقوقه وطالبا باقل المقتضيات
التي
[موسيقى]
وهي اهم شيء بانه هنالك هنالك فقدان
للامال هنالك فقدان لاي الامل في اي
مبادره ممكن ان تنطلق كان هنالك مبادرات
في فتره الاخيره ان كانت المبادرات
العربيه او المبادره الاردنيه وهنالك امال
كانت معقوده على المتابعه في على اقلها
على على تحقيق القرار خمسه اربعه او نرى
ان بعض يعني بعض المستجدات او الانفراجات
السياسيه في هذا السياق ولكن للاسف ليس
هنالك اي نوع من الانفراجات فلذلك من حق
هذا الشعب ان ينطلق
لاختيار مصيره بالشكل الذي يراه مناسبا
بعد ان فقد الامل تماما
باي مبادره ممكن ان تحدث نعم سيد خالد
جمول الناشطه السياسي والرئيس تجمع بنى
الوطن شكرا جزيلا لك
اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه نرصد مشهدا متوترا
ومتصاعدا بعد قصف الجيش التشادي مواقع
المعارضه المسلحه التشاديه داخل الاراضي
الليبيه وتدميره مخازن اعتاد واسلحه فكيف
يبدو المشهد نبدا بدايه بالموقع هنا على
الحدود بين تشاد وليبيا بلد غير ساحلي في
وسط افريقيا تحدها ست دول ليبيا من الشمال
وطبعا السودان
ومن الشرق وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى من
الجنوب والكاميرون ونيجيريا من الجنوب
الغربي والنيجر من الغرب وهي خامس اكبر
دوله في افريقيا من حيث المساحه ماذا عن
خصوصيه الجغرافيا بين الجرتين ليبيا
والشاد يبلغ طول هذه الحدود حدود شاديه
الليبيه بما مقداره حوالي 1000 وخمسين
كيلو متر وتمتد من النقطه الثلاثيه من
النيجر في الغرب الى النقطه الثلاثيه مع
السودان في الشرق ما الذي يحدث على الحدود
الشماليه لتشاد رئيس تشاد محمد ادريس دبي
توجه الى هناك وتحديدا الى براداي في
منطقه تيستي الجبليه الجبليه القاحله
الواقعه على بعد نحو الف كيلو متر شمال
العاصمه جمينا يقود المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
شاديه ان هدف الزياره هو حشد القوات
وتعزيز الانتشار الحالي بعد الهجوم الذي
استهدف مواقع وشنته عناصر مسلحه زعمت انها
تنتمي الى مجلس القياده العسكريه لانقاذ
الجمهوريه مجلس القياده العسكري لانقاذ
الجمهوري وهو من بين مجموعات مسلحات تسعى
منذ عقود للاطاحه بالنظام ارشادي كان قد
اعلن في اعلن في العاشر من اغسطس الحالي
تنفيذ هجوم استهدف جنودا شاديين فيه
منطقتي وور وكوري تقع المنطقه على 100 كم
غرب و150 كيلومتر شرق بلدي على التوالي في
ظل كل هذه المعطيات ما هي احتمالات يتطور
الوضع المشهد الميداني والسياسيا ايضا
يقول الرئيس تشادي محمد ادريس وهو يقود
قواته الان في منطقه كوري على الحدود
التشاديه الليبيه ان القوات البريه لم
تدخل الاراضي الليبيه حتى الان ولا مانع
لبلاده من دخول قواتها ليبيا تنفيذا
لاتفاقيه الخرطوم بين البلدان الاربعه
المجاوره
لليبيا هذا وكانت الدول الاربع وهي ليبيا
والسودان والنيجر قد وقعت في العام 2018
اتفاقيه تعاون امني لمكافحه الارهاب
والاتجار بالبشر وتطالب تشاد بتشكيل قوه
مشتركه على طول حدودها للحيلوله دون توغل
جماعات مسلحه طيب ماذا عن نظر التوتر
الاخرى
مجموعه الماضي اعلنت جبهه الوفاق من اجل
التغيير في تشاد الغاء وقف اطلاق النار
المعلن في ابريل 2021
متهمه الجيش التشادي بقصف احدى قواعدها
فيما وصفته بانه عمل من اعمال الحرب هذا
ويندر الاعلام الذي اصدرته الجبهه باحتمال
عوده الاعمال القتاليه الشامله بين
الحكومه التي يقودها الجيش وجبهه التغيير
والوفاق في تشاد طبعا كان القتال قد اودى
بحياه الرئيس ادريس ديبي في ساحه المعركه
عام 2021 قبل ان يتولى ابنه محمد ادريس
ديبي السلطه في البلاد ومنذ ذلك الحين
يسعد بصفته رئيسا مؤقتا الى دعم الوفاق مع
مختلف الجماعات المسلحه في تشاد واصدر
عفوا عن مئات السجناء التابعين لجبهه
التغيير والوفاق لتشجيعها على المشاركه في
محادثات السلام بصوره كامله طبعا للمزيد
ينضم الينا من نواكشوط الهيبه ولد الشيخ
سيداتي الخبير في الشان الافريقي اهلا بك
السيد الهيبه
هل يمكن عزل ما يجري طبعا وان كان ملفا
قديما ملف السلطه والمعارضه في تشاد ولكن
هل يمكن عزل هذا التحرك الاخير عما يجري
في المنطقه برمتها
مرحبا واهلا فعلا المنطقه
الجديده
تحيي وتزكي الصراع القديم بين معارضه
شاديه والمتمردين التشاديين والسلطه
المركزيه في تشاد التطورات التي حدثت في
يوم العاشر من الرشد والتي حدثت قبل ايام
بين القوات المسلحه
التشاديه الجيش التشادي والمجموعات
المتمرده من القياده قياده الجيش
ومن اجل من اجل الجمهوريه ومن مع جبهه
كلها مؤشرات على
تدني او انهيار السلام الهش الذي بناه
لابن مع هذه الجماعات يذكي ذلك فعلا
التوتر الحاصل في النيجر انهيار الحاصل في
السودان لنيار الحاصل في ليبيا منذ فتره
هذه اصبحت الصحراء امراء الحرب منطقه لا
يسيطر عليها الا من يملك القوه لا الحديث
فيها
والاصراع المسلح وبالتالي فعلا بؤره جديده
فشلت الحكومه المركزيه في تشاد من اخمادها
وهي الان توقد لتنظافه للازمه الحاليه في
ازمه الساحل التي لا تجد موطيه قدم
فيه الا وفيه ازمه او ازمتان الساحل
قوات المعارضه الشاديه تقول بان القوات
النظاميه كانت تقوم بعملياتها باتجاه
الاراضي الليبيه بغطاء من الطيران الفرنسي
ليعود مره اخرى طرح اسم فرنسا في هذه
المنطقه ماذا عن هذا البعد في ظل كل هذه
الحسابات المتطوره في المنطقه برمتها
ليس سرا دعم
فهي التي فرضته رغم كل مخالفه ذلك للنصوص
ولديستور
ليبيا في تشاد فرضتهم فرنسا هي التي فرضت
ذلك هي التي دفعته ايضا لهذه
المصالحه ودعامه المصالحه ابتداعا لكن
يبدو ان فرنسا المشروحه في النيجر
المطروده في مالي المطروده من بوركينا
فاسو تحاول الان استعاده هربتها واستعاده
كبريائها بعد قصف
الجيش التشادي في العاشر من
الناظرين بعض المتمردين فهي تحاول استباقه
هذا التمرد استباق هذه الازمات وتحاول
فعلا ان يكون
للحكومه المركزيه التشاديه لكن هيهات
منذ سنوات تعود الى تقهقر فرنسا بعد سنوات
ستتحول الى دوله اوروبيه مثل اسبانيا
وايطاليا عاديه لا تاثير لها في المنطقه
بفعل سياساتها وبفعل
غطرستها وبفعل تاريخها الاستعماري الذي
يبغضه كل الشعوب وترفضه كل شعوب المنطقه
ما الذي قد يضيفه اي انحدار او خلخل الوضع
في تشاد الى جمله المشهد السودان من جهه
النيجر من جهه ما قد يطرا عن اي عمليه قد
تقوم بها
بالاضافه الى دول ضعيفه ايضا كافريقه
الوسطى وغير ذلك
يبدو فعلا ان خيارات الغرب في هذه المنطقه
وخاصه فرنسا التي تعتبر بوابه الغرب في
هذه المنطقه
لتاريخها الاستعماري فيه
وجودها العسكري الكثيف في هذه المنطقه
يبدو ان خياراته اصبحت معنا او مع الارهاب
او تتحول الى دوله فاشله اذا لم يكن هناك
الخيارات التي نريد علينا ان ندعم التمرد
ندعم التطرف ندعم كل شيء حتى تفقد هذه
الدوله كيالها وهيبتها ووجودها وبالتالي
نعيد نحن الاقوى الموجودين على الارض مثل
فرنسا مثلا تعيد ترتيب الاوراق تعيد حمايه
نهب هذه الثروات تريد حمايه اليورانيوم
تعلمون اننا فرنسا قالت انها ترفض الخروج
من النيجر رغم طرد الانقلابيين لها لماذا
ترفض هذا وتقوف بهذه العشره ضد سلطه قائمه
في نيجيريا على الانقلاب السادس لم ترفض
له امرا شكرا لسبب ان اليورانيوم النيجيري
هو الذي يضيء السماء باريس وهو الذي يضيء
كل المدن البريئه الفرنسيه الهيبه ولد
الشيخ سيداتي الخبير في الشان الافريقي
كنت معنا من نواكشط شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تحضيرات كثيره وقلق متزايد من التاثير
المحتمل للتكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن
ثمه ما هو ايجابي فقد ذكرت دراسه للامم
المتحده اليوم ان احتمال تعزيز الذكاء
الاصطناعي للوظائف اكبر من احتمال تدميره
لها الدراسه التي تناولت التاثير المحتمل
لهذه المنصه وغيرها على كميه ونوعيه
الوظائف تشير الى ان معظم الوظائف
والقطاعات معرضه جزئيا فقط الى الاتمه
ورجحت ان معظمها سيكون على الارجح مكملا
لا مستبدلا باخر موجه ذكاء اصطناعي توليدي
مثل تشاد جي بي تي وبينما اظهرت الدراسه
تباينات كبيره في التاثير المحتمل لخسائر
الوظائف الناجمه عن الذكاء الاصطناعي بين
البلدان الغنيه والفقيره بل والافقر فانها
خلصت الى ان احتمال تعزيزها شبه متساوي في
مختلف البلدان طبعا نامل دوما ان يقدم
تطور التكنولوجي كلما هو ايجابي
ختام الحصاد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]